well I think the most surprising about
the leaks is just the amount of d d data
the data that was uh coming out of these
leagues is in regards to like Wolverine
uh the game play um them extracting and
making it playable um I do
think the
reporting of the the Leakes and the
punishing of the reporting of the
leagues I think is a bit overboard
because I think it's um you know a bit
unfair uh to be critical of people
Spreading the News because if this was
any other you know publisher or you know
developer everybody would be on it for
the clicks it's the hottest thing um out
there uh so the ad Revenue would be up
for everyone